howdy doesn't have to be hard it can be
but sometimes just two guys going what
if an eagle had an erection it's a big
big boner with wings well you see that's
there's so many different ways to
picture an eagle with an erection right
for some reason my first draft was an
eagle and it just a second beak it was
yellow okay totally legit yeah for me it
was an eagle big smile on his face and a
giant bear pink penis a bears no no yes
no no hair bare human you knew penis
yeah with no hair that's one way to
disappoint a lady be like you want to
see my bear dick you're just a
regular-sized dick okay
oh you mean there's no clothes on it cuz
I always really hope him for like a
grizzly bear Wow except because they
were like close with that Oh does that
mean this is the final question he's not
one of the weird feelings of life one of
the many weird feelings of life is when
it's time for the final question like
wait so final question for this episode
of the show not my life this is not a
Russian gameshow because I'm gonna be
honest with you that would bum me out
are you loyal to the KGB are you holding
an invisible yeah I put a silencer whoa
I can take it out looks like you're
playing with an Eagles penis
the big beer dick then you go out of
bear dick do I get to take one of these
home with me I actually don't think you
do ok no don't go he's not just passive
aggressively asking you if I could keep
this I am I got end up well don't get us
wrong you're a big get for us thanks for
coming
I don't know if that's true it is true I
don't know if it's it's true
tomorrow I'm interviewing one of George
Burns his old cigars
speaking of George Burns his old cigars
I've nothing to say that's another way
to disappoint a lady yes you want to see
George Burns is old cigar oh no it's
just a piece